[Music]
in language equality news ha yeah I
don't know that could mean submitted by
merci beaucoup merci
that's pretty good a French that means
thank you very much right I think so I
thought I'd men like please don't kill
me
yeah I think you're right my super cool
merci merci merci beaucoup
- Air Canada was fine for not using the
French language on flights but isn't it
mandatory in came a via government and
businesses to be bilingual they do have
bilingualism laws really in Canada
Canada so nice like they're so nice they
accommodate to like a very like smaller
percentage of the people's there right
well I mean there's a good chunk of
people that speak French
fringe is just is the primary size
official language in Kennedy to me I
don't know what the whole country I know
yeah yeah yes it's Quebec the bigger
region or as Montreal the bigger region
which was the city which was launched I
was a city I think Quebec is a prophet
the prophets uh I see Toronto Ontario
Canada yeah yeah yeah yeah um Vancouver
British Columbia Canada yep yeah oh yeah
I did a lot of research in Canada
because when I was there I was
completely confused
have you been to Cal have you been the
Calgary home in the Calgary yet I've
been to Toronto and Edmonton in
Vancouver I don't Oriya I've been not oh
yeah I want to go to Calgary whatever
much you like Montreal I got either all
French yeah that's what I do just seems
like a regular City i watch the mop show
on Canada though yeah what the do from
southern anarchy the dude who had the
cameras name okay
no no not at all he had a transgender
girlfriend
oh the crazy guy with the curly hair
yeah yeah oh
so in a Canadian mop show that's based
in a Montreal today it was whose
Canadiens went hard all the house them
Wow
we did it all nice and A's I only know
about Calgary Alberta because this home
of Bret to him the Hitman Hart the
excellence of execution crazy-looking so
that was my favorite wrestler when I was
coming up well and Shawn Michaels yeah
all right so this couple here they are
from Ontario oh I dunno French is a big
part of the culture because it's a
mandatory language for the entire school
system there everyone learns it a little
bit yeah
yeah so this couple here they filed 22
complaints against the airline back in
2016 and they recently won because they
took it up to like a higher court 22 all
you need is one that's a lot of
complaining like yeah I'll go again not
speaking French no this couple Air
Canada back in 2014
oh they got a [ __ ] huge as like yeah
exactly they got an agenda against the
five years of just complaining I I've
hated a marijuana I understand that pain
me too I don't hate any airline enough
to do that I hate speery airlines enough
and more but but they're so cheap though
yeah because you're sitting in freakin
luck on a lunch tray you can't acclaim
you can't recline it's hot but I I
always feel like if you Wi-Fi but you're
paying for what you'd like you're you
know what you're getting yourself into
but it's like you're getting a five
dollar hooker right and you know what
you're getting yourself into
is she bites your [ __ ] dick you can't
be mad
you can they don't advertise it as the
subway of the skies and they should they
don't they're like hey you just pay for
what you want no it's a [ __ ] crack
plane of the it's a crack house in this
case you'd be like it's like having into
an old taxi cab and then you're like
okay I get it doesn't make that's the
thing the quality of the plane like
engine-wise is good it's just like they
got the smallest amount of like how
close you can sit how small the seats of
a class we can't recline
there's no free water you can smile you
don't have to smile but don't you go
like thank God I got a good deal on this
no you don't Joe you say I cricket it's
not even worth it I know I'm if I have
to be on this I rather do
why don't you pluck won't you do another
poor Joe be poor and complain oh if I
had money I wouldn't be on spirit you
can still complain that we have that
right that's an American thing
happy fall spirit three times don't
worry because people are booking me on
spirit and I didn't realize it until too
late and that was the first light that's
my first like diva mode in my Ryder I
was like if you know spirit flights no
frontier fan you can only know Allegiant
they're bad too because they're Sochi no
it's already a change when I talk to the
sewers on Spirit wide attendant you're
sexist thief yes stewardess there's male
flight attendants the gay ones the gay
ones are stewardesses - there are the
flight attendants the what about steward
don't you see Stuart that's like you
don't say waiters and waitresses you say
servers that's the right word now what
about Bella right you say waiter Valerie
knows ok alright so they were saying
that there were signs in a domestic
flights that had the French language be
really really small and not prominent
and there were other signs I didn't even
have any French at all it was only in
English I didn't feel included so then
they said that did they must be English
yeah I do I mean they're able to file Oh
I mean there's other parties no no you
know what they're doing they're fighting
for the French people that can't speak
English that's what they're doing unless
you hit the button and then they should
talk to the stewardess yeah sorry the
not strippers I don't know what to call
your you're not super right okay cool
yeah question that's what I that's how I
usually handle it what if she
oh yeah well she could have a side gig
yeah I don't know I come here do you
ever go like excuse me huh this is what
kind of kitchen is this anyway so the
country's official languages act it
seeks to have English and French to have
an equal status among signs among
everything and so they're saying this
couple is saying la la air canada
doesn't have it because back in 2014
they were trying to sue right but they
were saying someone just [ __ ] them up
but they were saying they were trying to
[ __ ] tattletale on the lawyer who gets
there that's just like know what I don't
want to do this today like I get it like
yeah it's the law and it's good to
uphold the law and that's what everyone
agreed upon but the person that is
complaining about is a [ __ ] little
[ __ ] okay 115 thousand seven hundred US
dollars after all but that first one
they won fifteen grand that's like 20
grand in Canadian no I mean no that is
21 I literally thought that this would
be like a big million dollar thing or
some [ __ ] so they're preserving their
culture trying to do okay is that to my
next question is they dare they get this
money why because they pointed out the
culture because if if all they'd had to
do is just change the seat belts and the
science maybe that's how much money they
lost and that's and that's cool and then
because the people shouldn't gain
anything from it if they're trying to
preserve the culture 2014 one though
because of the emotional agony sitting
there and not hearing your language
lawsuit was really funny and I really
want to show that with you okay so back
into a fourteen they ordered a 7up in
French from the flight attendant but
instead they were they received a sprite
and so because of that they were saying
that Air Canada was violating the
language laws because there was a
miscommunication or like they didn't
understand or whatever it is so they
were suing for six thousand dollars and
they were awarded but
I try to preserve the culture like Gio
said the sprite is a French tree I tried
man I tried to be on their side yeah you
give it a good good shot you could have
made that mistake even if you were
speaking French like the sprite Canon 7
ok the difference is just like the
letters in the Red Dog you know what
else they do sometimes they they have a
contract with like Coke or whatever and
they only carry one so they know what
you mean but they're like we're gonna
bring you the closest thing to this if
you order sprite and they bring you a
root beer you have a lawsuit that's
different but that's when they finally
concluded that they can't get money that
the airline has to I mean that they just
have to settle for an apology from the
airline but there's actually started
back in 2009 just won an apology well it
took three international flights do the
same people every time they're these
same people are doing all these lawsuits
against the labor stings God dog why did
the airline let them use their their
carrier airline our blacklist both of
them thinking they did that you think
suing over sprite is bad now you got
banned now you got a million dollar
lawsuit there like finally baby work
we're almost there that's some fine
thinking I didn't think of that that's
great to people like this found each
other that's it
do you think that when they ordered like
how many flights they take and like can
we get a sprite please and they bring
this plane like alright yeah no it's fun
how do you order now that much why do
you fly Air Canada they said Air Canada
systematically violates the linguistic
rights of francophones
and so you know they're fighting for all
francophones what's francophones up
people French Canadian it no no like
French speakers
yeah French speakers that's like how all
the attorneys like when they do some
huge lawsuit all the attorneys get the
mind like we were fighting for the
people's rights and in
one gets like $1 you're the male and
they get million deal I know what's up
with that I didn't know that's how those
are class-action lawsuit whoever's the
lead plane they get paid the rest of
y'all should win the lead planet that's
called justice my friend my lawyer
actually read a class-action lawsuit and
I was just like are you sure are you
familiar with Yuna Ladd
yeah oh yeah I'm like lap Bible yeah so
they were they trade I use a video that
they claimed later in their in a one of
my videos and they were like you got to
pay us three thousand pounds for using
this video without licence and I was
like nah man my parodies law like all
that copyright stuff h3h3 goes like nah
man I gotta pay y'all nothing feels like
now it's four thousand dollars I was
like what so we like extortion yeah so
my lord like first I was talking to then
I give it to my lawyer and I'm like
first of all this like a UK company and
these laws are you know these are
American companies YouTube Facebook
Instagram so the law the law is American
not UK money but anyway the class-action
lawsuit was gonna be like my lawyers
like they did that to you they probably
did that to other people and other
people probably just got scared and paid
because the hell of a lawyer and they
were like it was like intense you know
thing but if you're familiar with what
you're what you're doing you're like not
no that ain't how this works that's
their business model that's their
business model because they can't get
you to pay the license fees and they'll
just get people to pay the scare tactic
thing because they don't wanna get in
trouble there are leeches in this world
oh absolutely and the biggest lishus
people preying on people who don't know
any better you paying people who don't
know they're just like oh this is easy
money that's the that's the jumping in
front of your car love of the the online
sense oh yeah absolutely absolutely
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you